l'année dernière la france a attiré 91
millions de touristes étrangers un
record qui aurait dû être dépassée en
2020 ratez pas de touristes étrangers en
france cet été
ça serait une première déjà dans les
années 50 les journalistes ironisé sur
l'arrivée en masse des visiteurs
étrangers
g allez dans les années soixante dix les
infrastructures se met en place station
de ski cité balnéaire mais aussi des
points d'informations pratiques deux
fois chouchouter les étrangers en
vacances dans l'hexagone
quelles sont les grandes questions pour
vous pauvres cherche à nos peurs car
c'est bien dans les années 70 que la
france voit le nombre de touristes
étrangers augmenter il était très jolie
lyon en 1970 25 millions six ans plus
tard le tourisme devient une manne
financière très importante
ils ont dépensé sur notre territoire 27
milliards de francs en devises pendant
leurs vacances d'hiver ou d'été cette
année on peut compter sur un chiffre
voisin de 38 le nombre de touristes
étrangers ne fera qu'augmenter 30
millions en 1980 75 millions en 1995 la
france devient la première destination
mondiale
la france reste la merveille du monde le
pays qu'il faut visiter p8 parade des
lieux les plus prisés notre dame bien
sûr disneyland paris et la forêt de
fontainebleau
les années 2000 aussi feront le plein
pour atteindre les 80 11 millions de
touristes étrangers en 2019 si de
nombreux touristes se plaignent du
mauvais accueil et du faible niveau dans
les langues étrangères des français
d'autres n'arrivent même pas à résumer
en un seul mot l'amour qu'ils portent au
pays so pas c'est super c'est génial
vraiment génial un mot chéri un mot en
sont d'accord un mot stimulante et libre
pour l'année 2020 le ministère de
l'économie prévoit y ait 60 milliards
d'euros de recettes grâce aux touristes
étrangers
un chiffre qui semble désormais
compliqué à atteindre
[Musique]